our tea an education some of the issues
addressed in neil bortz his new book
somebody's got to say it number three on
this week's new york times nonfiction
bestsellers list the libertarian radio
talk show host spoke about it recently
in marietta georgia for about twenty
minutes
hey folks wow thanks for coming out you
wonder about the cameras you can you
ever watched a book signing on c-span
before and now is gonna be your chance
by the way a couple of more rules this
wonderful chair here is provided by the
Relax The Back store because they know
what a Lucy I am and I need to be
comfortable also after you've had your
book sign if you want to have some fun
go out front and take a look at that
pray vote walk through it and it can be
yours tonight for a cool 1.3 million
dollars they may figure out the sales
tax on that alone is about seventy five
thousand dollars so but they might they
might give you substantial discount well
let's thank you royal by the way is he
great he'll sign your book too we need
another royal in Belinda are the reasons
for the success of the radio show
because I toiled in obscurity for years
before I got in the Royal in Belinda you
should have seen the look on Royals face
the first time I walked into a studio he
he knew for six months he was going to
be doing my show you were looking
forward to that weren't you yeah yeah
big it was huge I'll tell you a little
bit about the book tour so far we've had
marvelous success as of Sunday it was
something like 14 different cities and
15 different nights 13 airline flights
because it was just too far for me to
take my own plane we only ran into the
amazingly the best book signing thus far
was Dayton Ohio there is nothing to do
in Dayton Ohio
except yep read books that's all
especially during the winter but we've
only had two bad times one of them was
in Las Vegas now I was doing the book
signing in the showroom at a casino in
Las Vegas
boart's on stage in Las Vegas big but
the line snaked out into the casino and
so there was this guy that was wandering
around he said what's this for oh it's a
book signing what's the book it's called
somebody's got to say it
who wrote it somebody named neil bortz
who's that i hear that a lot
ah well he's uh he's a talk show host so
the guy just got in line no book nothing
and finally he makes his way to the
front I look up at him hi there what do
you have to say to a 57 year old man
that can't buy health insurance I looked
at him said don't get sick that was not
the answer he was looking for he turned
out to be a confirms well I want
socialized health care we need
socialized medicine and he kept going
and kept going started and so finally he
got escorted out of the uh out of the
casino then another one in Grand
Junction Colorado guy comes up I signed
his book and then he wants to argue with
me about Bill Clinton why why is Bill
Clinton not in jail I don't know why
didn't they throw him in jail I don't
know he moves off to the side of the
table I'm signing some other books oh I
get it you just don't want to talk to me
do you so no sir I would you know the
rest of these people in line can wait
till the cows come home let's just why
don't you just pull up a chair unless
spend the next hour and a half talking
about why Bill Clinton's not in jail
more importantly why the hell isn't
Hillary Clinton in jail
you know what let me let me tell you
something cuz I am a lawyer I'm a
recovered lawyer okay I'm no longer I am
no longer a threat but if somebody
serves me a subpoena for some documents
a legal subpoena and I say I don't have
them I answer in writing I don't have
them I don't know where they are I don't
think they exist and then I sign that
writing under oath and send it back and
then two years later those documents are
found in my office with my fingerprints
on them in my handwriting on them I'm
going to jail but then I wasn't married
to the president so I didn't get the
breaks now let me or I wouldn't get the
breaks let me tell you a little bit
about how this book came about I started
writing it a couple of years ago we
actually keep my daily program notes
have them going back what 12 14 years
now and so we'd start going through oh
this would make a good bet oh this would
make a good bit and we'd expand him in
the chapters and plug in little
insensitivity and so I stopped writing
this book that night that John Linder
and I had dinner and we decided to write
the FairTax book I'll give you an update
on that in just a second so I stopped
writing this book then we started the
FairTax book I went to New York and
talked to HarperCollins I said I've got
this book on taxes Sean Hannity put me
in touch with him I've got this book on
a tax reform plan I want you to publish
the guy looked at me like I was out of
my mind
that wouldn't sell nobody would buy a
book like that I said well you know I
got a radio show I think you'd at least
sell enough to make your money back well
maybe but are you working on anything
else I said yeah I got this thing out
there going called somebody's got to say
it well what's that I said that's red
meat that's from the talk show well
we'll publish that sight unseen we'll
publish that I said no I want to get the
fact that the FairTax book out there
first he said why don't you make that a
chapter of this other book it will
[ __ ] I said no it's got to be a
standalone book okay
we'll publish that if you'll sign a two
book contract and give us the other book
- I said fine so they they get the
FairTax book going we are we finished it
we write it they put it in a book form
and they print about 30,000 copies
that's it they think we're gonna get
this out of the way real quick and get
his other book in fact they made the
deadline for somebody's got to say it
fall just a couple of months after the
fair tic-tacs book came out so anyway
they start watching watching Barnes and
noble.com in about four weeks before the
FairTax book comes out it's number one
on Barnes and noble.com they say hmm he
may sell a few of these things so they
print another 10,000 copies and then the
book are 10 or 20,000 copies then the
book gets published and I can remember
right now we're driving from gee I'm not
sure we're driving from Orlando to Ocala
I think and I get a phone call from
HarperCollins Reagan books they say your
book just debuted number one on the New
York Times bestseller list so we got to
the hotel in Gainesville thank you we
got to the hotel in Gainesville and we
started drinking champagne and by the
time I got to the book signing in
Gainesville I was wasted
and the crowd didn't care and you can
tell any book that I signed during that
book deciding you can tell it was signed
that night in Gainesville Florida
because it looks like somebody just
drugged a dead bird across the page of
that book but I have some fair tax news
for you a week ago yesterday in Houston
Texas I had dinner with Leo Lynn Beck
Leo Lynn Beck is the man behind the
FairTax and Bob McNair who was the owner
of the Houston Texans AFL football team
these are the two guys that started
gathering the money to have the private
sector research done to come up with the
FairTax plan 22 million dollars and we
spent the whole evening just talking
about it
they have revamped Americans for fair
taxation they've replaced much of the
management in the leadership in that
organization and these guys are
determined that this thing is going to
happen we now have planned fair tax
rallies I don't have the exact dates now
so I'm not going to guess but Fox TV Fox
News has a presidential candidate rally
or debate coming up in Columbia South
Carolina sometime a couple of months
from now at the Koger Center we're gonna
be there with a fair tax rally
immediately preceding the debate then
the Republican straw poll in Iowa takes
place on a on a Saturday we're gonna be
there that Friday night with a fair tax
rally in Iowa and we're gonna try to
draw fifteen or twenty thousand people
to that rally if we can from all over
the Midwest and then we're gonna try to
keep them in Iowa overnight because the
next day if you're there you can vote
and we're gonna try to push that
Republican straw poll to whatever
Republican presidential candidate there
is that will promise if I am elected we
are going to get this fair tax done in
the 16th amendment to the Constitution
repealed so
so there's uh there's a lot of momentum
to it and in the book signings I've been
doing around the country I don't know if
you had fair tax books here for sale
tonight or not but I've been signing one
fair tax book for every three copies of
somebody's got to say it but now let me
tell you about somebody's got to say it
it's about a hundred thousand ninety-six
to a hundred thousand words long I got
tired of counting so tell him hi for me
sir
okay it's about ninety six two hundred
thousand words long before the fair tab
before we this was published I sat down
with an engineer and we recorded the
audio version of somebody's got to say
it is fifty five thousand words long so
you can see we left a lot out and the
recording an audio version is kind of
interesting because you read a page and
then at the end of the page you pause
they don't want the sound of the page
rustling when you turn the page over and
if you make a mistake you just stop back
up start reading again you have an
editor that is marking up the copy with
you along as you go and the engineer
that was doing the book with me every
once in a while in my ear I'd hear him
say oh boy oh boy
and then we'd pause and he said that
one's gonna cause you trouble we'd read
on another few pages oh you're gonna
catch hell for that about fifteen or
twenty pages later oh they'll never let
you get away with that and the one thing
that he thought I would get in the most
trouble for was my attitude on the
minimum wage so far I can't I haven't
caught hell for that one but basically
in the book I go back to that time on
the radio where I said barring a
physical or mental disaster that means
if you're not you know completely
physically incapable or mentally
incapable any adult in this country who
is incapable of earning more than the
minimum wage is a loser okay
that
well that caused me a lot of problems
when I said that on the air I mean
across the country columnist and
bloggers and everything or calling me
everything but a child of God so in the
book in the book you will see that I
repeat what I said on the radio and then
give it some more thought so you'll find
that in the book somebody's got to say
it but what really has caused me I guess
the most flak if you will is my thoughts
on teachers unions and they are not kind
and I said on the radio and I say in the
book that the teachers unions in this
country present a greater long-term
threat to our republic to our country
then do Islamic terrorists okay now let
me explain because I explained that the
book we're talking long-term not
short-term I realize that the alot Islam
fascist could come along and they could
detonate any kind of a bomb or a
chemical device I could kill 10 100 150
thousand people that would be a horrible
tragedy and the nation would mourn and
we'd be knocked back on our heels but we
would recover and we would go on from
there and we would find the people
responsible and we would deal with them
in a rather harsh manner but the
teachers unions odd note note please I
am NOT saying the teachers I am saying
the teachers unions can wipe out an
entire generation of Americans and we
don't even know the damage is done in
before until it's too late
now we have all over the cut right here
in Georgia we have to voucher laws that
are going through the General Assembly
one of them is a very simple voucher law
and it has to deal only with special how
many government school teachers do we
have in the crowd okay do you hate me
for what I'm saying No
it's not amazing it's like accountants
love the FairTax plan but anyway we have
one voucher system in this in this state
that's going through the General
Assembly that applies only to students
special students students or special
needs students that ride the short bus
call them what you will and it says that
if the school they are going to does not
provide the special education services
they need the state will pay X number a
thousand dollars to that student to be
carried off to whatever school they want
to go to not a private one but a
government one whatever government
school they can find where they can get
the services they want it is a limited
school choice program only for special
needs students the teachers unions are
fighting it they would rather these
special needs students fail to get what
they need in our school system than they
give one inch on school choice then we
have another voucher system another
voucher plan underway in Georgia and I
remember these numbers there are 102
schools in the state of Georgia
government schools that have been graded
as failing under the No Child Left
Behind Act failing for three years or
more 44 of those schools have been
failing for five years or more and under
the No Child Left Behind Act the state
is supposed to provide for these
students to get out of those schools
into a school that is not failing after
the second failing year there are 52,000
students in these 102 schools and there
is no system in place no workable system
in place to get them out of those
schools and into a school where they can
perform so we have another bill in
Georgia to institute a voucher program
only for the children in these failing
schools if the teachers unions are
fighting it tooth and nail and you look
around you folks could you
imagine what this books ever been into a
government bookstore have you ever been
into the federal book store they have
them go into a government bookstore and
compare it to a Barnes & Noble do that
go into any government-run enterprise
and compare it to a similar privately
run enterprise you know did you hear me
today what they're doing in the post
offices is this 37,000 post offices
around the country they have a postal
standardization program in effect and
they are removing the clocks from the
public area of every post office in the
nation so that you standing in line will
not have a clock staring at you to
remind you of how long you have been
waiting for these government employees
to get off their asses and take care of
you and what is what is the spokesman
for the Postal Service said we want
people to focus on their postal service
and not on the time you know and this is
carried over into the government schools
and wait'll you get socialized medicine
that's going to be even more fun well in
the book we also have a there's they're
serious chapters there's a chapter on
why you shouldn't there's why you
shouldn't vote for Republicans why you
shouldn't vote for Democrats why you
shouldn't vote for libertarians list
some of the reasons right there I was in
Asheville North Carolina I saw a
citizenship quiz in their newspaper the
last 4th of July it was a dumbest thing
I ever saw in my life
how many colonies were there who cares
who cares how many you know ask some
questions that mean something so I wrote
a citizenship quiz quiz it's in the book
I wrote a chapter in there of what
should be taught in government schools I
wrote a chapter about throwing cats out
of airplanes one day I heard Rush
Limbaugh on the air remember the Terri
Schiavo controversy why do you people
want this woman to die he asked on the
air so I did a show that day I wrote
something in my notes because she earned
it now I wrote that chapter in the book
I'm telling you right now I have had no
less than 30 or 40 emails from people
it's the chapter entitled because she
earned from people that are saying I
hated you when the Terri Schiavo think
was going on I couldn't believe what you
were saying but then I read that chapter
and you've completely changed my mind
there's also a chapter called no way in
hell that's right
that's for you people who have been
over-served and think I ought to run for
president you're not even sure I'm a
citizen okay so that chapters no way in
hell it's kind of like OJ's if I did it
it's called no way in hell I'm never
going to do this but if I did this would
be my platform it's in the book and then
the last chapter in the book is for
every one of you out there that says I
live from paycheck to paycheck and I
couldn't possibly save any money it's
the dollar bill savings program finally
put in the writing and in the book and
there's not a person in this room that
can't benefit from that so god bless you
thank you very very much for turning out
tonight and we're going to sit down and
start writing some books I'm sorry about
the personalisation thing but believe me
instead of being here for a couple of
hours we'd be here for two at two
o'clock in the morning you know because
some of the personalized personalization
requests like these two sisters walked
up to me in Grand Junction could you
write thanks for the great evening
I said you know what I don't really
remember that great evening they said we
can fix that Siri and then when I was
signing the FairTax book one time I told
John Linder after the book signing I
said John nobody not one woman who
slipped the phone number across the
table at me he looks at me and said Neal
you're old then I was reading a review
in the Austin american-statesman about
my uh my appearance there one day last
week I don't know signing books and the
guy that wrote the review neil bortz was
a lot leaner and older looking than I
had imagined were you laughing at that
yeah he's the leaner part I like the
older part consider the options okay and
I've never had so much fun in my life
and as for as far as the bald-headed
thing go go ahead and make your snide
remarks when you get up here let me look
around here let's see well I mean like
this guy right here in the front you see
the guys with hair one last thing God
gave everyone of us men the same number
of male hormones you can look around you
and see the ones that are using it to
grow hair okay and if that's what floats
their boat more power tool you know you
can get in a lot less trouble using your
hormones to grow hair then well never
mind I'm gonna sign books so thank you
very much for coming by proceed Royal
would like to sign to neil bortz hosts
the neil bortz show a nationally
syndicated radio program he's the author
of the terrible truth about liberals and
co-author with Congressman John Linder
of the FairTax book for more information
on neil bortz and his new book
somebody's got to say it visit bortz
calm